[Applause]
it was a night of celebrations for
supporters of France's new centrist
party la république on Marsh Republic on
the move the shekel seat William my dear
fellow citizens France is back for a
month the President of the Republic has
embodied confidence will and boldness in
France as well as on the international
stage the government at his side
illustrates through its composition a
completely new grouping and it's
determined to serve France and to
respond to the French people's
expectations
yeah they Paul was a doctor de Fauci
pollsters predict that the party could
win 400 or more seats out of 577 in
parliament after next Sunday's second
round a majority that will be crucial to
push through controversial reforms to
Work and Pensions
but voter turnout was at a record low on
sunday and opponents from both sides of
the political spectrum say that means
president McCulloh doesn't have the
mandate to carry out those reforms
far-right whole national leader marine
lepen called on citizens to use their
votes to stop their cons clans what
Oliver we need some real members of
parliament who will oppose the
catastrophic policies Emanuel McConnell
is preparing he's about to commit a
slaughter with labour laws that will
send millions of workers into
instability without bringing anything to
companies there's also concerned that a
huge parliamentary majority for la
république on marche would leave little
room for debate as far left leader
jean-luc mélenchon warned Odadjian boo
in the second round
do not give and don't allow anyone to
give total power to the president's
party politicians are now racing to get
people to the polls for next Sunday's
runoff
you